chump is made it easy to see that you
don't really want that kind of world
that he's painting
Megan Markel has bowed out of meeting
Donald Trump a source tells ET that the
Dutchess of Sussex will not meet with
the president when he arrives in the UK
next week for a state visit
according to the official schedule for
his upcoming trip Queen Elizabeth will
host Trump and his wife Melania during
their three-day stay Prince Charles and
Camilla will be in attendance for the
official ceremonial welcome at
Buckingham Palace garden which will be
followed by a private lunch that same
afternoon Prince William and Kate
Middleton are scheduled to share a
private tea with Trump and yes Prince
Harry's name is also on the guest list
so it's just Megan missing out on a Fab
Four appearance the Duchess of Sussex is
currently enjoying maternity leave with
her son Archie who will be less than
four weeks old when the state visit goes
down so she could be skipping out for
that reason though it's worth noting the
37 year old new mama has criticised the
president publicly in the past it's
really the moment that I go we film
suits in Toronto and I just stay in
Canada right I'm gonna become on like if
that's really the reality that we're
talking about come on that is a game
changer in terms of how we move in the
world that was Megan during a 2016
interview on the nightly show with Larry
Wilmore talking Trump before he was
elected into office and before she
joined the royal family yes of course
Trump is device and think about just
female voters alone right I mean like he
was in 2012 like the Republican Party
lost a female vote by 12 points that's a
huge number and with this misogynistic
as Trump is and so vocal about it that's
a huge chunk of it you're not just
voting for a woman if it's Hillary just
because she's a woman but certainly
because Trump has made it easy to see
that you don't really want that kind of
world that needs painting
[Music]